welcome to plate to date today I have  three gentlemen making glances for me I  cannot wait I'm David I'm Ian I'm Andrew  what I'm looking for in a man being  open-minded is a big one somebody that's  open to trying weird things number one  thing I look for when I'm potentially  dating someone is intelligence like I  could talk to this person every day for  the rest of my life I'm gonna use like  some garam masala I'm gonna use some  ginger because I can't use garlic and  onion so I'm just gonna hit you with  everything else from all these different  angles it definitely does not look the  way I hoped it looks kind of weird but  the flavor is gonna be good this is my  flavor Blends a flavor it looks like an  omelette  he's creative  the suspense is killing me just say if  it's okay or not  I like it yeah  and I think he tried like  [Laughter]